[Music]
in coop attempt news submitted by - with
cash Vietnam
jailed a US citizen for attempting to
overthrow the state that's crazy that
one man why do that well the government
is claiming that he's worked with other
people and like to to other people so
three total have been jailed because of
this so they're claiming that he wanted
to incite protest in Vietnam and he was
planning to attack government offices in
Hanoi and Ho Chi Minh City with petrol
bombs oh so he's American terrorist so
he was actually born in Vietnam but he
became a US citizen after the Vietnam
War and so they're saying that because
he lives in the OSI that that's where
like this radical group lives as well oh
yeah if you go there you see it yeah we
still we still shoot a bunch of stuff
over there there's a lot of like anti
Vietnamese communism like centers with
flags all over the place there's like
they'll be like a little pickup truck
with like all kinds of propaganda just
going up and down the streets yeah and
it go down hell yeah I don't know what
it means but they say Wow yeah and then
they have the Vietnamese flag that's
yellow with three stripes and that was
the south vietnam flag yeah and then now
it's the red with the yellow star yeah
and then they still call Ho Chi Minh see
they call it Saigon cuz it used to be
that name and then when the north took
it over
they changed the name I didn't know that
yeah so all the majority of the
Vietnamese people in the States are
South Vietnamese so when the North and
South went went into war the South was a
former French colony that was also on
the side of America America came to help
him out so when they lost they got
refugee status with America and that was
a lot of southern Vietnamese soldiers
camp cambodian like freedom fighters
that helped you know the US soldiers
navigate through the jungle Hmong people
and like a lot of Vietnamese Chinese
people that they were like Chinese
people that ran away from communists to
Vietnam and in Vietnam turned communist
and they had to run away to the
somewhere else and then uncles yeah in
an uncle Chan coach and Uncle Sam had to
run away - oh is that their origin story
yes yeah yeah so it's a it's an
interesting clue because you find you're
fine yeah cuz the Vietnamese in Vietnam
are like communist Vietnamese and in the
people that are in America still hold on
to the southern Vietnamese culture they
hate men go to hell is what they say
yeah I used to live and work in
Koreatown and after work one day I saw a
ton of Koreans and they're all outside
on the lawn and and I was like boo [ __ ]
there's some kind of protest and I was
telling everybody like there's a protest
out here and it turns out they were out
they were all out there and there's a
huge monitor outside and they were just
watching the World Cup realism yeah they
get crazy I was like why are they so
pissed because they were yelling like in
Korean that this man yeah like come
outside we thought they were all pissed
so maybe what the ref did them dirty I
think oh maybe could have got a pointed
out point taken away or some could be
but they unite over soccer like crazy
was fine it was alright so the guy that
has been sentenced he is a 55 year old
father of four and he was Michael and so
he actually got sentenced to 12 years in
prison in Vietnam and once he's done a
little center he will be deported wait
so they came to the states and grabbed
his ass and pull it back over there no
no he was oh yeah I forgot to mention he
was visiting Vietnam he was stirring up
[ __ ] in Vietnam a it got him I see if he
was there and so the two other people
that the government claims were on his
his team they got eight and ten years in
prison for the same offenses and so
they're adding that they will face three
years under house arrest after serving
the prison terms because those two other
guys are Vietnamese men like Vietnamese
citizen so pretty early thing like if I
can bomb this
one building then I will will overthrow
the government it's gonna make a
difference or something it's nuts yeah
yeah I know that's crazy I mean this is
being reported by the Vietnamese
government but Michaels family they're
obviously saying that he was never
involved in any sort of radical group
and like he would have never been
involved in this whole thing that he's
being he's being charged with oh this is
Michael falsely accused perhaps did
their uniforms are really green didn't
he plead guilty to something but then
not the bombing but the attempted
bombing so I think that's why yeah so he
did plead guilty to trying to do a
protest but not so actually what the
foot causes family like he would never
be involved in it is really making light
of the situation I don't know the black
guy that's like calling them like their
black guy yeah the podium like wait
you're not in jail for 12 years was
there proof that he was gonna have the
bombs or like into the mom delusional Oh
his mom yeah you say his mom is saying
that it wasn't em right it's family oh
yeah um not that I know of but I the
only other thing I do know about the
trial is I lasted half a day this was a
very quick trial that's right no no cuz
I miss communist and Tom communist
countries I just don't know about how
real that [ __ ] is like they just say
whatever they want because we have a lot
of close friends that live out there and
they like are deep in the movie industry
out there and they said that everything
is government controlled like everything
like they have to approve everything
every movie whatever yeah yeah yeah so
now there are a lot of activists in the
u.s. trying to get him to be immediately
released because he is a US citizen so
can you imagine trying to over it like
what if he really was trying to
overthrow that country and in like
restore it to the
southern vietnamese days or something
that's well cuz only had three people or
two people next to him maybe he watched
V for Vendetta and [ __ ] you know and
then he was like hell yeah that's all
you need you know you got empower the
people they are looking for another
person okay so three people yeah on the
run can you imagine just like living in
a country that's like that period
because people think America is pretty
bad but it's not that bad yeah I mean
dude [ __ ] Jack yeah that scares me I
mean they look at what happened to our
warm buyer that kid who was in North
Korea yeah [ __ ] crazy he like
stole a banner that was in a hallway or
something yes [ __ ] him up and then
they he came back and as soon as he like
touches US soil he's like oh yeah yeah
yeah no he was already dead oh they sent
him back to head yeah not much ilysm he
was like brain dead or something yeah so
they he he ate some [ __ ] or they
basically that's botulism yeah it's just
it's probably a message or whatever it
was what is the budget went it's like a
brain thing I get affects your brain
right and it's like you could get it
when there's like food that's all [ __ ]
up it expired canned food or something I
feel like they made him eat something I
don't know oh well it's not really
conspiracy like we know that he died
when he came home we just don't know
what I see yeah I see well if they
definitely [ __ ] him the [ __ ] up I mean
that thank God I thought they sent him
home dead he was basically dead he was
dead and a bunch of [ __ ] they apparently
had taken out part of his brain or some
freak yeah that's what blows my mind is
like a lot of these places still exist
right and then people just want to live
a normal life and you just don't know I
rather be a part of the government in
that case of course cuz if you want to
be towards the top of the food chain in
those situations yeah always I mean any
situation I'd rather be the shot-caller
like imagine being the cartel you don't
want to be the farmer in Mexico you want
to be the cartel
yeah well actually not cuz you're gonna
die eventually we want to be you want to
be you want to be the guy what that's
that's walking the dog country that I
have to deal with this I want to be here
fantasizing about being in the cartel
emotion
this is exactly right what's what's our
refuge though like Norway like what's
our place where we want to run away from
Canada yeah but it's too cold what I
like to hear though I don't feel like
running away nobody what if the country
went to [ __ ] I would say Canada if we
went to [ __ ] yeah it's like like I don't
know like if the Communists took over
you know I go to Mexico with all my guns
Mexico
I know but then it's so wild all weather
just disorganized I can probably find a
jungle and just build my own little show
they're so peaceful and happy and they
have ketchup chips too cold too cold
it's pretty cold but I think I'm okay
Canada wah-bah Hawaii well how are you
anything I know but they might not go
through the same [ __ ] cuz they don't
celebrate like Thanksgiving and stuff so
they might not care I'll probably go to
[ __ ] Texas do them that's like the
heart of them no but I'm saying my tea
I'm saying nobody's gonna [ __ ] with them
dude like you can try their America they
will be it will be the insurgents in the
[ __ ] weeds attacking every week I
would definitely go to Canada it's only
option
what if there's too much and they build
a wall they're like stop we're screwed
I'm being like the woods somewhere
isolated like Wyoming there's not that
many people there it might be kind of
good that's why I like Canada cuz it's
so [ __ ] big and they have such a
small puny military very tiny military
so I feel like they couldn't really find
you that easily it's all a lot of in
uninhabited areas in Canada name kind of
dog hmm I'll try to go to Hawaii maybe
they wouldn't take me though now cuz of
the deads but that's okay I get it
you're all set what if the other parts
of the world is safe but America like
The Handmaid's Tale or like these other
I mean yeah it totally makes me think of
that like yeah then the head meet still
like this crazy what is it like a
religion future right
yeah there's still be a future yeah I'm
watching it last night oh is it you know
about it then so yeah like it's this
whole different future where people
can't be
they can't have kids anymore and the
women who can have kids they end up
being a handmaid which means they get
[ __ ] once a month by the man of the
house and try to get pregnant but these
men are also infertile and like it's
just a creature like elite families and
stuff yeah and then like if you step out
of line at all they'll hang you in like
the town wall where everyone sees your
your dead body that's crazy
yeah some games games with orange chip
yeah it's pretty wild well so but then
people are running to Canada trying to
find refuge there because America is so
[ __ ] so it's scary cuz I like do that
[ __ ] happen too scary
[Music]